tonight the kremlin is accusing the us
of an economic war on russia one day
after president biden's ban on russian
oil and other energy imports this is uh
unprecedented that a
large economy 150 million people
has been literally
walled off from the rest of the global
economy within a matter of days
working in unison western governments
have turned russia into the most
sanctioned nation in the world and sent
their economy tumbling uh
it's a complete 180. this is
the end of an era
of 30 years of integration
the hope is that by crumbling russia's
economy it will persuade vladimir putin
to end his war in ukraine
the only thing that we can do with these
sanctions is to bleed him dry so that
there is no money left for him to
execute this war
the estimates are
that the gdp of russia is going to
contract by 30 percent immediately
30 gdp contraction is the equivalent of
the great depression that took place in
america it's going to be a savage
horrific effect on the russian people on
the russian economy and on everything to
do with russia
there's not going to be a single person
who's unaffected by by what's coming
up
in some respects there's almost a shock
at all treatment with respect to some of
these sanctions you know the stock
market has been sort of seized up
essentially since the day after the
invasion you've seen hundreds of
companies international companies leave
so all of that i think has had an
immediate effect on the economic
economic fortunes of russians
will it achieve the ends
uh that are intended which is
to get putin to stop waging war i'm not
so sure about that
[Music]
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
the eu uk usa and nato partners are
pouring military equipment and aid into
ukraine
but there's a limit to what they can
offer
because the west has decided it doesn't
want to engage militarily with russia
another nuclear power the only tool
they've got left in the toolbox is
sanctions
and
they're going to hit hit them with
sanctions as hard as they can the
russian oligarch crackdown continuing
russia's oligarchs the elite owners and
managers of industry have been targeted
their jets and boats impounded their
bank accounts frozen we're seeing
evidence that really any russian links
are proven pretty problematic whether
that's in business or culture so i've
been campaigning for 10 years to toughen
up on putin and toughen up on russian
criminality in london
and i felt like i was knocking on a
closed door and then all of a sudden in
two weeks everything that i've been
trying to do for 10 years has become
possible
bill browder was once the largest
foreign portfolio investor in russia but
after blowing the whistle on massive
corruption he was targeted
his lawyer and friend sergey magnitsky
was detained allegedly beaten by guards
and refused medical care before dying in
prison in 2009
well london is to russia as hong kong is
to china every
russian who stole money every oligarch
every corrupt official
wants a place a safe place to keep that
money
and london has a rule of law it has
property rights
and most importantly nobody's going to
ask any tough questions from law
enforcement here
for decades russian money was welcomed
by lawyers accountants and politicians
even in the face of an alleged
assassination and attempted
assassination on uk soil
alexander litvinyenko's death from acute
radiation sickness was slow and
agonizing
in 2006 former kgb officer alexander
litvinenko a fierce putin critic died
after being poisoned then in 2018 former
russian military intelligence officer
sergey skripal and his daughter were
poisoned with the nerve agent novichok
in the english city of salisbury
they lived but a british woman who was
exposed to the nerve agent died
so the uk
historically took no action against
anybody for anything you could kill
people using
nuclear materials and there would be no
consequences you could shut down a whole
city with banned chemical weapons and
there'd be no consequences
and so the uk has got a terrible
reputation as far as
permissive
attitude towards russian malfeasance
[Music]
the west's response to russia's invasion
to ukraine has been much stronger than
anything seen before
the uk which was criticized for being
slower than the eu and usa on sanctions
is now in line
and i would argue that that the british
government is now
acting appropriately toughly and i'm the
biggest critic of the british government
when it comes to this and i can say that
you know i'm impressed with the
sanctions that are now being imposed
the invasion of ukraine has caused
outrage across europe and nations that
once tried to economically integrate
with russia are taking action against
president vladimir putin and his
government
i think he completely underestimated
the appetite of western governments to
impose punishing sanctions i think he
thought not only would the war in
ukraine be
as easy as annexing crimea that it would
be over very quickly but he did not
count on
unity amongst europe european countries
as well as the us and the uk
to impose punishing sanctions that would
cost their economies as well as his
they're looking at this this incredible
coalition
um you know pacific the atlantic you see
the japanese the australians even
jurisdictions like switzerland that have
historically stayed far away from this
kind of thing are stepping into the game
and away from the sidelines which is
just an amazing scene
so all of that suggests that we are in
an unprecedented time uh and so
unprecedented time means that there's
going to be incredible unprecedented
effects uh frankly both planned and
unplanned so i think that we need to
look for both of those on the economic
side and the political side as well
the speed and unity of action by western
governments has caught some by surprise
after years of disagreement between
european nations about how and if to
engage with putin's russia
eu countries have been shocked into
coalition
the western world has finally woken up
to the threat that
russian president vladimir putin poses
and so the sanctions have been
unprecedented
in terms of hitting hard the russian
economy from every angle
everything from
freezing uh some of the russian central
bank's
reserves foreign currency reserves to
kicking russian banks out of swift the
financial messaging system
limits or bans on russian oil and gas
the list goes on and on and the goal
really is to
deal a devastating blow against the
russian economy
sanctions are really only as strong as
the weakest link if you have differences
and designations differences in who's
being targeted
that you could clearly uh take advantage
of that
historically the europeans including the
uk pre-brexit have not been uh
particularly aggressive on the
enforcement front in the eu side uh
sanctions implementation is done by
brussels but enforcement is done by the
27 states member states independently
and of course each state has different
capacities different political interests
and different concerns and therefore
enforcement has been somewhat lacked
lacking compared to the united states
and so i'm concerned about whether we're
going to get enforcement which is
actually where where the teeth can
actually come out come into sanctions
i mean look at the history of sanctions
and the two most high profile cases iran
and north korea it hasn't worked at all
if anything it's only strengthened the
regime so there is a real question about
sanctions as a tool
in a situation like this will it really
work or will they perversely strengthen
putin
so vladimir putin doesn't care about
sanctions against his officials he
doesn't care about sanctions against
russian state companies he absolutely
profoundly cares about sanctions against
russian oligarchs because those
oligarchs hold his money and you can
just look at his reaction when
when the british government started
talking about sanctioning oligarchs that
was the first moment when he started
threatening nuclear war it's the thing
he cares most about vladimir putin is a
man who values money
more than human life
but not everyone agrees that president
putin can be targeted by going after his
foreign assets there are many who think
that
there are oligarchs in the west that are
essentially putin's banker
but in reality i've had other people
tell me
he doesn't need that he has the entire
russian state at his disposal to use he
doesn't need someone else to be his
banker because he has all these
state-run companies that he can use the
cash flow from to do whatever he wants
and while targeted sanctions may not
change putin's mind sanctions on the
russian economy are being felt by
ordinary people the sanctions will
essentially decimate the russian middle
class which many believe is key to
building some kind of democratic state
and i think there's an assumption that
you inflict so much pain
on ordinary russians that they will rise
up
and demand
changes or overthrow the government and
again i think that underestimates
russian history and the power and
of the kremlin
for browder sanctions don't need to have
any higher ambitions than throwing a
spanner in putin's war machine it's a
hugely expensive war a billion two
billion dollars a day is spent on this
war he doesn't have access to his
central bank reserves uh he doesn't have
access to his oligarch capital
he doesn't have access to external
financing and the purpose of this is not
to get somebody to change his mind is to
make sure that he just doesn't have
enough money to do it and this is how we
won the cold war we basically bled them
dry and we have to do that again
how this all plays out isn't entirely
clear because we've never been here
before
russia is now the most sanctioned
country in the world
and it's at war we have not been here
before
so
uh
it'll be an interesting test case can
you
[ __ ]
an economy
and starve it of the resources it needs
to wage war
well
that
depends on a number of factors if china
comes in and bails out russia with
weapons uh and other
financial support then they could
continue to wage this war uh
for quite a while
so i think the way that china could
potentially aid russia is by serving as
a payment conduit right so russian
institutions certainly the big ones have
essentially been shut off from the
international community but chinese
institutions of course haven't been and
there's no reason that you can't sort of
funnel a payment uh from rubles to
rumimbi and then out if you go by
shanghai or beijing or buy hong kong
dollars in hong kong
i'm not sure china wants to sort of risk
their rise their sort of soft power um
on sort of getting into bed very very
closely and intimately with someone who
is so reviled on an international basis
if the u.s then responds with secondary
sanctions on china
for dealing with russia then that cuts
out that other escape route
that putin potentially has so
the world is unified but not entirely
unified
[Music]
you